let's talk about indictments next six
months ago I would have said Jared
Kushner was going to be the next sort of
big inside player from the Trump
Organization Trump campaign Trump staff
to get indicted we did a poll last week
on our YouTube channel and 42% of our
audience said that Donald Trump jr. is
going to be the next insider to get
indicted in the Trump Russia probe we
have now heard from Trump friend and
confidante and prior guest on this
program Roger stone he has gone public
with the claim he is asserting that
Donald Trump jr. is about to get
indicted a political insider spoke to
Roger stone that's a right-wing
publication you may not be familiar with
spoke to him over the weekend and Roger
stone said quote I predict based on
excellent sourcing that the special
counsel is going to charge Donald Trump
jr. with lying to the FBI notice they're
not charging him for having an illegal
meeting with a Russian at Trump Tower
because there's nothing illegal about
that meeting there are about ten
interesting things about this that we
could talk about I want to just focus in
on a couple of them today first of all
who are Roger stone sources that would
know if an indictment is coming for
Donald Trump jr. either that's a lie or
he has some interesting people he's in
touch with which we would want to know
more about that's number one number two
Roger stones claim that Trump jr. isn't
getting indicted for the Trump Russia
meeting may be both accurate as of right
now and highly deceptive and what I mean
by that is it may well be true that
there isn't already an impending
indictment or a sealed indictment for
the meeting in Trump Tower that Donald
Trump jr. was involved in the planning
of and participated in we don't know
that John Don jr. has extensively
discussed that meeting or that if he has
that Robert Moeller has finished his
investigation into that meeting or to
say it in a different way Robert Moeller
has been waiting on a lot of the family
insiders and he may merely not have
gotten to a full investigation of Donald
Trump's jr. specific role in possible
criminality surrounding
meeting almost every week there's new
information about that meeting who knew
what and when did they know it who
planned it who said what what
pre-meeting discussions were there what
follow-up discussions and actions took
place it would almost be surprising if
molar was ready to recommend indictments
for the meeting itself
what Muller may already know and this is
if we believe that Roger stone is is
telling the truth here
what Muller may already know is that Don
Jr lied about the meeting or about
something else because what stone is
claiming is that the indictment would be
for lying to investigators but now let's
get to the most important thing here
whether it's true or not that Donald
Trump jr. is about to get indicted
why would Roger stone go public with the
allegation a couple possibilities-- at
the top of the list is that stone wants
to goad Donald Trump into firing Robert
Muller as soon as soon as possible
maybe to interfere with Roger stones own
possible indictment it is getting to
sort of now-or-never for firing Muller
because the indictment the guilty pleas
the guilty verdicts they are now in full
swing it's not going to be that much
longer before it hits the family or the
real insiders if it's going to so then
the practical question is let's say
Roger stones lying he doesn't really
think Don juniors getting indicted or if
he thinks that maybe he doesn't actually
have specific inside information if he
succeeds at getting Trump in a panic to
say Don juniors getting indicted I'm
firing Muller now does it actually stop
the indictment of Don junior because
very often these indictments are written
up ahead of time and sealed and if
that's the case it's not even clear that
firing Muller would stop the indictment
of Don junior as far as the merits of
whether Don junior is likely to get
indicted remember when Steve Bannon said
during an interview quote they're going
to crack Don junior like an egg on
national TV others have also speculated
that Don juniors in trouble so it
certainly would come at no surprise in
the end there's likely so much going on
with the investigation that done none of
these speculators actually
anything about with George papadopolis
remember it was months after his
indictment and guilty plea that we found
out about it so anything could be
happening and the bottom line is that
stones motives could involve deception
to prevent him from ending up indicted
by Robert Muller's investigation the
content of it the idea of Don jr.
getting invited in and indicted in and
of itself that's not surprising we've
been talking about a Don Jr indictment
for a while now and even more over the
last two to three weeks but never
underestimate what individuals are
willing to go to for the purposes of
self-preservation
that is what's motivating a lot of what
we're seeing Michael Cohen the longtime
love of Donald Trump just their love for
each other so strong and amazing and
unbelievable supposedly at a certain
point it was about Cowen's family and
not his loyalty to his love Donald Trump
and he did presumably although we don't
yet know to what degree he's cooperating
what he and his attorneys determined is
best for him to do they are sort of
scramming like rats trying to abandon a
sinking ship at this point and that's
what's one of the highest motivators
self-preservation for themselves and for
the integrity of the families of a lot
of these people if you're not following
the David Pakman show on Instagram you
should go to at David Pakman show on
Instagram behind the scenes pictures you
can ask me questions all sorts of great
stuff is happening there at David Pakman
show on Instagram you can also follow me
at David Pakman I'm really thrilled to
tell you that today's program is made
possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman as many of you know I have
been working very hard on this program
to reduce stigma around mental health to
reduce stigma around seeking help and I
have a family that is very involved in
mental health and if you've not already
heard about better help it is a
tremendous resource better help gives
you through your phone and computer
affordable private access to licensed
trained accredit
experienced psychologists counselors
therapists and clinical social workers
who were dedicated to helping you
through whatever is going on in your
life you just go to better help calm
slash Pakman fill out a questionnaire
they will match you with a counselor
that will work best for you
they are LGBT friendly you can even say
I want a counselor who's not religious
if that's important to you if your
initial match isn't a good vibe you can
switch to a different counselor and the
beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description if you're
watching on YouTube once again that is
better help calm slash PA que ma N